this week at the moment we've been
putting in the very earliest of our
pansies and as well as our ranunculus
and then through into June and we'll
finish off with our bulbs there's no
real way of avoiding the bending there's
plenty of time spent on the hands and
knees during this time of the year but
we do have a few tools that we use to to
alleviate some of that we stagger our
planting dates through the nursery one
to assist with them and their bench
space and allow us to plant throughout a
period of about eight to ten weeks other
one we're currently planting there's
about 450 pansies that have gone into
the border and approximately 250
ranunculus in the middle but in Queens
Park Gardens here we'll be looking in
the vicinity of 35 to 40 thousand
seedlings and approximately five to six
thousand bulbs it is a lot of work but
well worth it
you